hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see com where we give you
reasons to see and not to see Jack
Reacher so let's hang out Ryan's
consensus I would have to say there are
a few strong reasons to see recharge a
creature there are a few strong reasons
to watch Jack Reacher kind of in the
middle on it you know kind of luke-warm
cherries consensus for me I think there
are some reasons to see Jack Reacher
there are some reasons to see Jack
Reacher honestly I had high expectations
for this film but at the end of the day
I can't go off of you know what I
thought I would watch I have to go off
of what was given to me I didn't go in
expecting a heck of a lot i went with me
I'm of interest but you know at the end
of day you know I enjoyed myself reason
to see number one Tom Cruise Tom Cruise
badass man Tom Cruise is always bad at
yeah they're like 20-30 gets cooler as
time goes on yeah there's a time where
everyone thought he was a little bit gay
but now I don't even care yeah I'm mad
new he's the [ __ ] and he looks great for
like a 50 year old man yeah yeah no I
mean it maybe maybe he is gay and that's
why he looks so great he's charming he's
funny at times too and he sells it Matt
he's very believable as this guy who can
beat up five people at once the
detective skills that he naturally has
its it's shocking just how believable he
actually it is for a guy who's like five
foot two or something why did I know
that I know a lot of people said in the
book dude supposed to be like don't like
a gorilla you under catch something
giant guy but you know Tom Cruise the he
nails it man and I think like he's the
strongest reason to see this movie yeah
I think Tom Cruise is the reason to
watch this video
a bit talker is the reason of his
mission yeah cuz I don't think the movie
itself is that great but in the day the
films called Jack Reacher so how is Jack
Reacher well Tom Cruise delivers on
being Jack Reacher and watch it jack
reacher adventure again it's like as
long as Tom Cruise is back solving some
mystery kicking people's asses I hope
you pick I won't complaint is uh he
doesn't have that many running scenes he
doesn't have that many running scenes or
scenes where he like bursts out in
smiling yeah which is different for Tom
Cruise real ray perfect posture perfect
posture hungers reason to seat number to
the action I thought the action style
that he chose for the film was perfect
because it's kind of going for stylish
but realistic tonality with the action
and I thought they executed it very well
if it perfect for the character you know
he's an ex army guy and this is a movie
that's very great a very dark and it's
there's this weird balance they have
between realism and over the top because
everything is yelling over the top but
for some reason doesn't feel that way
for a lot of it I gotta give it up to
the action because like those car chases
you know the fights you know everything
is really well captured really well
choreographed so I mean I was I was
thrilled by the act I gotta admit
Manning Tom Cruise is 50 Liam Neeson's
54 the two of them should just do a
movie together because they're the
oldest guys you can kick the baddest
asses yeah you know like with Tom Cruise
fights in this film I want to [ __ ]
people up to yeah you want to join it
uses a burner you want to be as cool as
he is and drive muscle cars and beat up
thugs yeah you want that moment where
you're like oh come on come on come damn
it I'm gonna dress the the shifter for
the right time until it's my time to
speed on a reason to see number three
Werner Herzog but that hot Sun no yeah
good oppression I kind of feel weird
about him because I like him a lot in
this mood like I like his presence a lot
I'm not sure the character life fits the
movie quite right no this is a 19-3
movie yeah is it going Indiana Jones
Adventure her more like some kind of
almost like that scum kind of warped
Bond villain almost be eccentric villain
but but at the same just from the
performance at element like it sometimes
feels like he's in a different movie but
I always liked watching workers are like
I feel like the character tells
everybody his story about why you got
miss Pinkerton that's his whole thing
it's like hey I've been my fingers off
you should do it today reason to see
number four Jai Courtney I thought this
guy was very cool in this movie he had a
great setup in the beginning he's very
believable he brings a charisma a type
of charm to the performance that doesn't
seem pretentious or force which you can
see in a lot of villains where they try
to be all smiley and whatever but he
naturally just brings a charm that was
just at the right finality and he's a
good match for Tom Cruise he's a bad
dude and he doesn't want to dark things
there's a scene where he has to sort of
switch it up and pretend to be a
different person for a minute to lure
somebody into a trap it's like Charlie
when he had to be charming I bought it
when he had to be sinister like I bought
that tues reason to see number five
Robert Duvall all dudes King enhancement
devolves always committing to the
performative that he's doing he makes a
great cameo and him and Tom Cruise have
really good chemistry even when parts of
the story don't make sense or even when
you know things are over-the-top you
know I still believe time why was he
killing people
but he doesn't have helping Tom Cruise
do some pretty drastic stuff you would
have to replay to think about why are
they so cute I with episode you know he
would you know they have this like a
couple scenes together and then all of a
sudden he's helping him with this big
you know like master plan and I'm like
why why are you here exactly do you just
like hanging with Tucker if you have
nothing else better to do that they come
shoot up a bunch of people reason to see
number six Alexia fast that girl's hot
she's hot and cute at the same time yes
rare combo and love it yeah great when
you're eating popcorn it takes skill she
brings layers to the performance yeah
sure you know she has scenes where she's
kind of sexy and seductive yeah and then
she also has seen for she's like bawling
her eyes out but it's not over dramatic
she does a really good job at it and I I
was a little bummed out what happened
will give it away but I got bummed out
at one point but I liked her generally I
mean not just looking at her I also
liked listening and comprehending what
she was saying she's really hot she is
hot yeah yes
you